was it a mind-blowing dream for you when
willard scott started to slow down they
started to determine that he wasn't as
hot as he used to actually and this is a
true story yeah willard was the one who
decided he wanted to step back but it
was a dream come true when you got that
that's the gig of a life oh yeah i mean
look when i got to new york and you
remember because you were we had wnbc
robin
when i got to to do weekends at wnbc i
thought you know what this is the
greatest
maybe frankfield might leave in four or
five years and i might get you know the
the early show during the week you know
the the
so
the the honor god's honest truth the
today show wasn't even on my radar right
you didn't say oh this is my ambition
yeah
please you were just happy to i was so
thrilled the first time because i don't
know if you remember live at five don
pardo would be the you know doing the
intro and the first time he said al
roker with the one i thought this is
this is how did you get that job i mean
were you were you was your ambition to
be a news man
my ambition
to be perfectly honest i did not plan to
be on tv i really didn't i was i was
going to be a producer or director
something like that a writer and at the
end of my sophomore year in college at
suny oswego i got a they were looking
for a weekend weatherman and my my
department chairman who had told me i
had god's honest truth i had the perfect
face for radio put me up for a job
doing weekend weather at when in
syracuse new york that's a tv station
it's a tv station
you wear a sophomore in college at the
end of my session and a professor says
to you
go uh try out for this job as a
weatherman i did a tape at school he
took it down for me
uh because he worked part time at the
station that's a miracle how many guys a
sophomore in college get any kind of job
if it wasn't for him you might never
even thought to do this not even it
wouldn't he wouldn't have even been on
my radar and you went down there and you
passed the audition right away did the
audition uh the guy gave me the job i
was making ten dollars a newscast
were you awful you were the newscaster i
was the weatherman weatherman i was the
weather were you awful at it i wasn't
good did you have an affect were you
were you were you were like trying to
find i know i was horrible on this you
know i was i was kind of like just
you know just kind of doing funny stuff
you know but not nervous yeah i was
nervous in the beginning you know but uh
after a while i mean i think the the
like you one of the things is you forget
after a while you're on tv or you're on
radio you're just you you know yeah but
that happened rather rapidly but you
know look me was at that time a 19 year
old college sophomore so how good could
that be so when when you did this you
said hey maybe i could make a career out
of this well you know what i was
thinking i'm going to do this until i
can get a real job directing or doing
something like that right and then i got
a job in washington dc which is where i
right out of syracuse yeah
six months after i graduated a guy one
of my competitors sent the tape to a
friend to get me out of the market wow
wow that's which was nice yeah it's like
hey i don't even
i wasn't even looking for a job